voici l'atoll de mururoa en polynésie
c'est ici que la france réalise son 41e
essai nucléaire
le 17 juillet 1974
nom de code centaure un échec qui se
transforme en échec
non seulement le champignon atomique ne
s'élève pas à la hauteur prévue par
l'armée française mais en plus il prend
une mauvaise direction cap sur tahiti
d'après une enquête signée disclose près
de cent dix mille personnes auraient été
exposées à la radioactivité pour ce seul
essai nucléaire
ce qui représente la quasi totalité de
la population de tahiti et des îles sous
le vent à l'époque disclose révèle aussi
que ces contaminations auraient pu être
évités le 17 juillet jour de l'essai de
centaure les prévisions indiquent que
les masses d'air pousseront le nuage du
scat haïti et sa capitale papeete
les militaires le savent mais décide de
ne pas confiner la population le nuage
de sang et or attend la grande île 42
heures après infectant massivement ses
habitants
les essais à l'air libre réalisé de 1966
à 1974 comme centaure sont les plus
contaminant il y en a 46 selon disclose
en touffe en trente ans de 1966 à 1996
la france procède à 193 essais
nucléaires depuis les atolls de mururoa
et fangataufa
l'enquêté révèle aussi que les doses
radioactives reçu par les habitants ont
été largement sous-évalué lors des six
essais atmosphériques les plus
contaminant pour chacune de ces
estimations
nous avons identifié plusieurs erreurs
dans les calculs réalisés par le
commissariat à l'énergie atomique
en 2006 elles concernent notamment
l'absence de prise en compte de l'eau de
pluie dans le calcul de la dose reçue
sur tout le corps par la population
résultat les estimations du cea en
matière de doses maximales reçues sont
entre 2 et 10 fois plus faibles que
celles obtenues par nos estimations pour
évaluer les retombées de l'essai baptisé
des bars ans les scientifiques du cea
sont partis du principe que les
populations locales ne buvait que l'eau
des rivières
or selon disclose certaines consommer
aussi l'eau de pluie des éléments qui
expliquent donc les différences entre
les estimations des personnes impactées
par les doses radioactives
à ce jour hormis militaire et
prestataires d'entreprise seuls 63
civils polynésiens ont reçu une offre
d'indemnisation de la part du civ n un
comité créé par la france en 2010
il est chargé d'indemniser les victimes
des essais nucléaires
un nombre de victimes reconnues bien en
deça donc de la réalité